الآن
[موسيقى]
مجموعة غامضة من المرتزقة أو
أداة مهمة لروسيا في ساحة
المعركة في أوكرانيا، تصدرت مجموعة فاغنر
عناوين الأخبار منذ
غزو روسيا لأوكرانيا، ويقودها
تقدم يفغيني لرجل الأعمال الروسي
والشريك القديم للرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين الفاغنر.  تُعرف المجموعة
بتكتيكاتها الوحشية ومشاركتها لفترة طويلة
في الصراع،
بدءًا من التدخل الروسي الأولي
في أوكرانيا في عام 2014، ولكن أيضًا على سبيل المثال
الحرب الأهلية في سوريا، كما أن المجموعة
نشطة جدًا في إفريقيا الآن بعد أن
قامت مجموعة فاغنر  سلم
مواقعه في بلدة باهاموت في
شرق أوكرانيا إلى الجيش الروسي،
ما هو التالي بالنسبة للمرتزقة وما
يمكن أن يكون دورهم المستقبلي في الحرب
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
لذلك في ظاهر الأمر، تقول الاحتياط
أن المرتزقة قد خرجوا  فاهمود
لأنهم فازوا بالمدينة بشكل أساسي،
يقول إن مقاتليه استولوا على كل
باكمود وبالتالي فإن عملهم
يتم هناك الآن، ومن غير الواضح ما إذا كان
هذا هو الحال بالفعل أم لا أو ربما
ينسحبون لأنهم يعتقدون
ذلك بينما  لقد تمكنوا من الاستيلاء على
أجزاء كبيرة من الباكمود، وسيكون من
الصعب جدًا السيطرة على تلك
المدينة إذا قام الجيش الأوكراني
بالرد.
تقول جهات أجنبية إن مجموعة فاغنر ذهبت إلى
باهاموت ببساطة لأنهم أفضل
من الجيش الروسي لأن
الجيش الروسي  كان يكافح
وأصبح الأمر
مهمًا للغاية بالنسبة لهم من
منظور دعائي، وظلوا يقولون إن قواته
كانت تحقق مكاسب في باهاموت بينما
لم يتمكن الجيش الروسي النظامي من
تحقيق أي مكاسب في ساحات القتال الأخرى
عبر أوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
لذا فإن السحب  يمكن أن يكون لخروج مجموعة فاغنر من
باكو
تأثير كبير جدًا على الحرب في أوكرانيا، إنها واحدة من
تلك الأماكن التي
كان فيها الجيش الأوكراني في موقف دفاعي، وكانت واحدة
من تلك الأماكن التي فقدوا فيها
الكثير من الجنود وخسروا أيضًا  الكثير من
العتاد بالإضافة إلى نفس العدد بالنسبة
للجيش الروسي، فقد تكبدوا أيضًا
خسائر فادحة جدًا على الرغم من أنهم كانوا
يحققون مكاسب هناك. أحد
التحولات التي من المحتمل أن
تراها هو أن الجيش الأوكراني قد يكون
قادرًا على توحيد قواته حول
باكموت والانطلاق  هجوم مضاد
وهذا بالتأكيد شيء يمكن أن
يؤدي إلى تحول في الزخم كما
يقول الأوكرانيون إن القتال حول اقتباس باهمود
يظل مركز العداء
أم
أنه سيعيد تجميع صفوفه ويجدد أيضًا
تجنيد المزيد من تقدم المقاتلين
يقول بالتأكيد أنه بينما يقوم الآن
بسحب قواته  لم ينته
من هذا الصراع، ويقول إنه سيحصل على
أوامر جديدة من
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين على الأرجح وسيعود
إلى الحرب بمجرد تلقيه
تلك الأوامر